Caleb Presley faked his own death on me
and
and he well he almost died and so at
least
you know
he's willing to put his muerto where his
mouth is you know so that at least I
respected that but
what happened was he was in the hot heat
something happened to him I don't know
what happened to him he had a you know
he could have some bad salad I don't
know maybe he
you know
he lost too many bets on bar and well
you know he I don't know what happened
to him but he I think he you know he
lost probably a couple hundred bucks on
North Carolina
and next thing you know he's in the
hospital he's on a ventilator
and so I'm on an airplane I'm flying on
an airplane somewhere and uh
and I get a damn
um
I get a
a message from Will Compton if you're
not familiar with Will Compton he
um
he is a member of blessing with the boys
and they are a
they're kind of a
um
avant-garde or whatever it's called I
think or one of them is an avant-garde
Taylor there's two of them will and
Taylor are the two men that are on it
and
will yeah Will is like a
Taylor is like an avant-garde he's like
a
football tackle and he
he also looks like he would be like the
like one of the Final Bosses at like
kind of like a Renaissance fair
but like
with a little bit of a Paxon Vibe
throwed in right
and then will is kind of like he's like
this
he only he's like a crash chest dummy
for CTE kind of he's like basically he's
that dog you know they're both dogs
they're both dogs
but will
um will text to me I'm on this airplane
and he said did you hear what happened
to Caleb and when somebody says that
you're like it's two options
either Caleb
is
unalive
or
or whoever the person is that person is
either un alive or they won the lottery
or something right
so I'm like I don't think Caleb even
plays the Powerball or nothing so
I'm like what happened you know he makes
you knew the what happened like gee and
I'm on a plane so it's like it takes
four minutes I have to restart my phone
get it back on the thing
and it said that he passed away
so I'm sitting in the plane man I start
just breaking down you know
um
I'm just you know
I'm shook
and I even told the guy next to me you
know I mean he could see something was
kind of wrong and I looked over
and I said um
my friend just passed away
and
he goes do you want to go pee that's
what he said
and I'm like what kind of sick dude does
this guy think I am that if somebody
dies
that I gotta go hold my dick for some
reason or you know like
he didn't know there was no condolences
or nothing
you know and that kind that shook me man
like
my friend passed away and he's like oh
do you wanna you wanna go pee
you think cause
like what what about looking at me makes
you think cause my friend is gone
that I want to pee that I want to go
hold my wiener in a small room and have
water come out of it you know
I mean we're just losing touch with each
other man
but yeah for about 20 25 minutes
um
I thought he was deceased and uh and
then I get a text from Will
and um
and he said hey man uh we're just joking
or whatever we just had burritos or
something like that you know some just
typical you know just real Sig app just
some real Sig app [ __ ]
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one